parce qu'on peut on peut les uns et les
autres s'écoute et se respecte et et
monsieur ciotti sera très heureux de ne
pas l'entendre de bruit pendant son
intervention
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le premier ministre
et j'y associe le député maire de menton
jean claude guibal lundi soir à menton
s'est noué un drame qui a mis en cause
un déséquilibré qui a été abattu par les
policiers de la brigade anticriminalité
ce forcené qui a menacé les policiers
avec une machette avait pris l'autoroute
à sens inverse et l'issue de ce périple
s'est terminé tragiquement cet individu
était bien connu des services
il avait été placé en hospitalisation
d'office en octobre 2010 pour des faits
similaires il avait poursuivi des
passants avec une tronçonneuse et il
avait été interpellé dans les mêmes
conditions dramatiques où il avait été
blessé par les policiers
la levée de son hospitalisation d'office
je vois que certains rigolent mais je
pense que c'est plutôt tragique son
hospitalisation d'office a été levée le
2 juin dernier les policiers qui ont
intercepté courageusement cette personne
et auxquels je veux rendre hommage ont
été placés en garde à vue aujourd'hui se
pose la responsabilité de ceux qui
prennent les décisions de levée de
l'hospitalisation d'office du suivi de
ces personnes connues et identifiées
pour être particulièrement dangereux se
pose la question du suivi psychiatrique
on sait qu'il y a des problèmes majeurs
on sait qu'il ya un déficit de moyens on
sait qu'il ya des personnes qui sont
placés en détention alors qu'elles
relèvent d'un suivi psychiatrique
monsieur le premier ministre je veux
attirer votre question c'est votre
attention
sans polémique sur cette question celle
de la responsabilité celle de la
responsabilité qu'ont fait subir aux
policiers par la faute des autres
celle de la responsabilité du suivi de
ces personnes extrêmement dangereuses et
celles des moyens qui sont mis en oeuvre
pour suivre le profil de ces personnes
qui menacent la société je vous remercie
merci monsieur ciotti la parole est à
même la ministre des affaires sociales
et de la santé marisol touraine
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
ciotti ce qui s'est passé lundi dernier
à menton et tragique et je veux à mon
tour salué le sang froid des forces de
l'ordre et des policiers qui ont été
agressé par un déséquilibré
armé d'une faucille ou d'une machette
mais moi monsieur le député je ne veux
pas opposer les professionnels les uns
aux autres il n'y a pas d'un côté les
policiers et de l'autre les médecins et
les soignants qui chaque jour dans les
hôpitaux psychiatriques font un travail
difficile et remarquable est cet homme
cet homme déséquilibré avait quitté le
centre hospitalier dans lequel il était
soigné à l'issue de deux avis médicaux
favorable il avait un traitement que
l'on qualifie de faible intensité mais
je veux vous dire monsieur le député une
enquête administrative est en cours au
sein du centre hospitalier de la même
manière qu'une enquête judiciaire a été
engagée
mais pour ma part je crois que face à
des événements aussi dramatique
nous ne devons pas donner le sentiment
qu'il y à des professionnels de santé
qui n'accomplissent pas leur devoir avec
la volonté aussi de protéger la société
et encore une fois je rends hommage ici
par delà le cas particulier qui s'est
produit à menton et dont je veux redire
qu'il est tragique
je veux une fois de plus rendre hommage
aussi à celles et ceux qui travaillent
dans les hôpitaux psychiatriques parce
que leur mission est indispensable
difficile exigeante et elle doit être
salué merci madame la ministre
la parole est à monsieur le président
denis baupin